this one might be familiar to you United
States Canada Mexico Panama Haiti
Jamaica Peru
okay well listen to this United States
Canada Mexico Panama Haiti Jamaica Peru
recover Dominican Cuba Carribean
Greenland El Salvador - where - Rico
Columbia Venezuela Honduras Guyana and
still Rob Paulsen
has a voice that helped define 90's
cartoons okay well let's see I'm Yakko
Warner hello nurse I love some thinking
from thinking in the brain and for those
of you who are fans of Jimmy Neutron I'm
Cara I'm the little fat guy and you did
Raphael from the original Ninja Turtles
right yeah Raphael sounds a lot like me
yeah say things like shredder you tin
face deep get back here and taste cold
turtle steel and all the voices they
have a background story oh no I feel a
flashback coming on let's go well did
the inspiration from pinky come from
well for me it was a large part of my
deep abiding love for British humour
music you joke to you pinky knock knock
Peter Sellers was a huge inspiration but
um for some reason mr. Spielberg and his
infinite wisdom decided it was a good
fit with Maurice LaMarche who was the
brain so here we are
wait Steven Spielberg oh my god there he
is he produced Pinky and the brain and
Animaniacs
will wait and he did Saving Private Ryan
twister men and black and Schindler's
List while he was making these cartoons
okay
[Music]
IMDB site wreck over sorry back to rob
okay great
okay so Yakko from Animaniacs where did
his voice come from only our hairdresser
knows for sure they decided on this
little sort of helium based voice that
kind of a smartass vibe a la Groucho
Marx hey Batman does Dracula know you're
wearing his cape so badly and as for the
song where he sings every country in the
world the interesting thing is it only
took me one take to record it
the song is a beautifully crafted piece
that's the difficult part not singing
you can hear him we're in goof troop
Darkwing Duck gummy bears Tiny Toon
Adventures the list goes on this guy's
kind of legend I don't write them and I
don't draw them I'm just a singer but it
is cool thing to be associated with
those shows it's pretty cool nobody
cares what I look like so I can do it as
long as I can breathe
[Music]